when you became a presenter on GB news
you agreed to the editorial Charter yeah
that's true which you broke right well I
don't know if I broke it definitely did
I mean I've I've read it it says You
must respect the opinions of others and
those people and we've already agreed
not to go over all ground but we've
already agreed your comments were
disrespectful to so you did break it
which is look people are going to break
rules and that happens so I I have to
say from where as an outside Observer I
I think your criticism of GB news is
unreasonable in this situation they have
to they have to suspend you no I'm I'm
not saying don't suspend probably sack
you and and therefore how can they
defend your right to say it if they're
suspending you for it how can they do
that the from their perspec of they're
going we're regulated by ofcom Lawrence
has broken our rules he's broken ofcom
rules yeah so I think the issue you're
fighting against here is that GB news is
an ofcom regulated broadcaster and not a
YouTube channel let's say right so but
you know just to again in
terms in terms of context I told them
exactly what I was going to say
including the word shag I said who would
R to Shag that and they were giggling
away and they were giggling away right
up until the moment the mob came for
them so yes i' I've gone past the
editorial thing also by the way I'm
totally happy to get sacked no I know I
know but I'm I'm saying your criticism
is unfair it seems to me well I I don't
I think GB news are what is the point in
labeling yourself the hope of free
speech if you're going to cancel people
for free speech it's an oxymoron
therefore if your business model is to
be the home of free speech then either
campaign to have ofcom removed or do it
online surely because if you you can't
it it ofcom have proven that free speech
is not celebrated in this country we
look at the whole point of GB news
existing in the media landscape was
because every single other news channel
was saying exactly the same thing so GB
news came on and the M the media have
looked at them and said well we get them
somehow we'll get them someone will do
it and if it hadn't been me that trod on
the mine it would have been someone else
who trod on the mine at some point you
know and that's what that's what would
have happened but the what scares me is
the fact that
um everyone wants them shut down that's
what scares me now I think that
they should have been a bit busier about
the whole thing if I'm honest I said I
think I think what they should have done
is instead of utterly completely condemn
me they should have turned around
they possibly phoned me and said listen
you what on Earth was going on and I and
let and let me at least explain as I've
explained here what's going on and then
take a pause to work out what is their
position on this have you spoken to
anybody though no no one's called me at
all I was on my phone I was on my phone
and I you know when you get those news
things appear it like Lawrence Fox SP
from GB news and I actually laughed CU I
thought that's so funny that no one
would even send you a you know a message
or anything like that so yeah I mean it
is what it is I mean look to be fair to
GB news they are I mean it's a tough
situation to it is a tough situation
because for context for people watching
from overseas they've got an advertising
boycott against them so they're
hemorrhaging money they've got people
pressuring them they've got people
criticizing them they've got the entire
media ecology against him and all of a
sudden this ecology broadcast ecology
that's the one right you know so in a
way it is understandable Lawrence yes no
I'm not I'm not going it's all we fault
it's all my I think we've gone through
the I think we've gone through the
struggle session of it's all my
fault no I hope it hasn't been a
struggle no no because I think look I
I'm yeah you know I just to me in my
brain I just find a whole idea of
ofcom stunningly ridiculous well this is
what I'm saying to you is you're blaming
GB news for being regulated yeah yeah I
think I think that's kind of what you're
fighting against and by the way just so
that doesn't feel too much like a
struggle session particularly on the
broadcast ecology Point there's actually
a few videos that I want to play for
people to get a little bit of context
about what can happen on other channels
uh and what people do on other channels
and no one demands those channels are
shut down so we have a clip of the man
we just saw Adam Bolton uh this is how
he used to speak to when he was on Sky
News by the way uh he still works for
rer Murdo it's having to go at GB news I
wonder if that's a complete accident
anyway let's play this
clip yeah if if if Beth comes put her in
there and then she can go away I know I
know just put the [__] seat
in
have you got have you got the grab
yeah yeah well she's going to come and
[__] sit here if she wants to be on
telly the great BJ speaking yet no are
you going to attend well in
theing past few
minutes uh Mr Johnson
arrived what the what the [__]
sit down there stop [__]
around
yes well uh Beth is here uh you can see
uh Johnson speaks when it happens around
lunch time the
best great respector of women that guy
yeah but I I actually defend him you do
because yeah he wasn't on air and if you
I mean God forbid what GB news have got
stored in the cupboard of things I've
said when we're not on air I can see why
you're defending him no I don't care
because I'm think he wasn't on air yeah
I'd much I'm much were interested in the
woman this morning who turned around ear
yesterday on timed radio in the middle
of the day and when Lawrence Fox is a
dick M because I wonder is that the same
level of well right and actually perhaps
more to your point we have a clip from
Sky News talking about the Martin Basher
Affair who of course tricked Princess
Diana we don't even need to play it
because I think we we can retell the
story he tricked using fraudulent
documents Princess Diana into give an
interview while working at the BBC
Russell Brand sax gate happened while he
was working at the BBC I mean we could
go further into the history of BBC
presenters Behavior on and off screen uh
without making this too uh too non
so all of that was wrong I think all the
people were reprimanded of the ones that
were you know available to be
reprimanded at the time but nobody
called for the BBC to be shut down
Philip Scofield's Behavior didn't result
in ITV being shut down or anyone calling
for it to be shut down so the I think we
might have done M yeah no one was paying
attention to us exct they are now so my
point is what I where I do agree with
you is there is clearly a politically
motivated campaign to shut down GB news
by let's be honest their Rivals yeah and
well the but also the establishment yeah
the establishment narrative so this um
media uh e ecosystem whatever the I've
forgotten it now it called broadcast
ecology um that reaches out doesn't it
because it's a massive institution the
BBC and uh stuff like that it the
broadcast ecology reaches out into the
cultural Ecology of what is and isn't
acceptable where the over window sits
within Society GB news you're right I
should separate out my um criticisms GB
news wanted to shift
that uh well to do its best to to
provide let's face it 51% of the
population with something to watch that
they might learn something from or agree
with and JB news often listens to its
audience it doesn't tell them what to
think it doesn't use that broadcast
theology thing but it all expands out to
fill up our entire culture so you know
newspapers will write the word she I was
speaking to a journalist the other day
and I was like why do you go a picture
of a big scraggly bearded man with a wig
on and say woman arrested and charged
with um sex offenses she will be sent
you know like why do you do that and
they say it's just easier for the sub
editors to do it because if someone
doesn't write she then you're going to
get a complaint from someone else going
but he says he a woman you know and it
it it broadens out and out and out and
out and out and affects our culture and
I think I've just rambled into my myself
into a corner what was I trying to say
no you were talking about the the
broadcast ecology yeah so the broad so
separating out offc Comm is right why is
off Communists the offc Communists which
is what they are essentially anything
with Comm on the end of it is Comm they
just stands for communism elcom we get
elcom the reclaimed party El communist
we get fined um investigated
relentlessly nonstop unlike any other
political party where and we're tiny
like this you know so I think there's a
determined effort not only to shut down
GB news but I think there's a determined
effort to shut down anyone who is
confident and okay to share an
[Music]
opinion